you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everyone welcome back
to the game sports co-op stage here on
the show floor at e3 2016 I'm Lucy James
and most joining myself and dave jared
is matpat from the game theorists hey
I'm in a middle eat we've been here for
an hour already I know it's no big
surprise what's our adjective for this
segment so we're talking about oculus
sony playstation vr okay five bethesda
vr oh man it is the ii III of VR that's
it is Tom me vr is the winner of this e3
yeah always hey because like I've seen
you try out before and you get motion
sick oh yeah real bad I'm fine advised
yeah but um I a friend of mine who I
used to live with was a developer for
oculus like he did some architecture
stuff it wasn't gaming but he had a he
had an oculus early had said and just
walking around in that thing back before
is the constellation sister everything
it just made me so sick really I get
sick from first-person shooters like a
sick maiming so walking too quickly
seriously time I had to quickly and I'm
down um but no I think like recently I
think the VR has overcome the motion
sickness problem you haven't played the
consumer version of oculus but I here
obviously they couldn't sell it if it
was gonna make you sick right right yeah
so at this point I I've been fortunate
enough to try oculus 5 the Samsung gear
and I spent a lot of time this III
playing around with a PlayStation VR as
well since that was such a big
announcement for sony and i have to say
i'm very excited by everything that VR
represents the gaming space is there
always going to be room for 2d
experiences absolutely but VR opens up
gaming to a whole new dimension and
there's so many cool experiences that
are just waiting out there and to me I
said vr is the overall winner of e3
specifically PlayStation VR took took
the convention hands down yeah in my
mind playstation be out for me is
probably the one that like I've always
loved the idea
and the ones I've tried like I would
adore a vibe but it seems like what VR
you get is also kind of hampered by late
your living situation there's so much to
think about when you're getting four
yeah like I can't get a vibe I'd be
clattering into all my soul I haven't
got enough space its PlayStation VR I
can sit down where I normally sit down
in front of my console it's easy I've
already got the technology there I don't
have to fiddle around with my computer
I'm not relying on new software just by
getting my playstation that's probably
the one I'd get but the wall I'd really
adore is like the tactile vibe yeah the
whole big vibe experience like I mean if
money was an option I'd have a house
with a five-room like hollowtech that's
the dream holiday we have in the office
room like a hallowed ecru it is called
the holodeck yeah that's awesome it's
just a disused office oh it's like a
disused like cubicle it sounds a lot
cooler though when you call it Kyler's
yeah the hollow decker the VR room
that's great it's got a glass wall so
every time yet you all came to get
coffee just sees you see someone like
waving around in the air yeah they'll
tell you what like playing VR not the
way to look very cool like you just kind
of waving things in the air but when
you're actually in the headset you feel
cool like one of my favorite moments of
VR the c3 was getting to test the the
Batman experience oh yeah for
PlayStation and it's it's a fairly
simple you know experience it's pretty
short relative to some of the other ones
that are on the show floor but you'd put
on a cowl the bat cowl you put on the
bat gloves and then you see yourself
like in a reflection and then you kind
of solve a mystery but seeing the
reflection of you dressed as Batman and
seeing your hands become like the bat
gloves and the cowl come on kid you not
like one of the it's so simple but it's
so effective yeah cuz he's like
responding to your motion I like I I had
to lean into the mirror and be like I'm
Batman good because you just feel so bad
ass doing it yeah and and win us an
experience that simple is that effective
and that kind of like visceral you know
you have something special there yeah
what I mean what I think though is so
nice especially they announced you know
those final fantasy 15 our experience
there's star wars battlefront basically
I just want them to make x-wing vs. TIE
fighter ya think but it seems like it's
just one mission
you know 15 isn't going to be part of
the main game this is going to be a
select few mission yes Batman is also
just like it's like experience none of
these things are big games right it's
just an experience to give you a taste
but I'm really interested in seeing what
the next thing is gonna be real well i
think you know and and there's already
cuz so like on the vibe there are some
longer-form experiences out there right
so on on our live streaming channel
we've started experiment with a a chair
a game called a chair in a room uh which
is the lamest title for a game ever but
it's this like psychological horror
experience it takes place in six
chapters each chapter is about like you
know 45 minutes long depending on how
long you exist in the space um and it's
it's psychological horror that put you
in this world you're starting to like
get a sense that things aren't quite
what they seem and it and it's really
effective yeah and and so I think that
there's room for kind of those shorter
form experiences where it's like a cool
10 minute 15 minute demo you're in
you're out you're scared whatever and
you end and then there is room for kind
of those longer form games where you're
you're assuming the role of a character
you're immersed in this world um and it
just kind of like does the game does the
story that you're trying to tell fit
that format and I think that's the
biggest thing right now and that's what
has truly separated good VR from bad VR
for me is when the VR is an essential
part to the story telling that's when
it's good VR so I played a couple games
on the show floor here that you know the
VR experience wasn't adding anything for
me in fact it was subtracting from it i
played this one 3d brawler game where
you're kind of its its resident evil
style where you go into a room and your
fixed camera position than you move
forward and you get into a different fix
timer position and you as you are the
camera and you're looking but you're so
far removed from the action that
although like fighting and the the
brawling is so muddy it's hard to tell
what's going on and I wasn't feeling
immersed I was feeling very distant from
things and I the question I ask is why
was that in VR whereas you know be
Batman or undergo this psychological
terror by going through this like weird
mind-bending thing um the most effective
VR experience that I had this III was
that evil 7 I was gonna ask you if you'd
played it I did that was definitely one
of the things that I went to first first
hand like right off the bat and as soon
as I put the headset on I'm like oh this
was a terrible idea in the best way
possible you know like of course I'm
putting this on to get scared and as
soon as you're in that world you're
hearing the sounds from the other side
of the door you're like you feel the
dread just sleeping it into you and one
of the things that it's so hard to
convey to people watching you know
online without having experienced this
is there's no escape yeah you know yes
you can rip the headset off but outside
of that you know if they want you to see
something you will see it if they want
you to hear something you will hear it
and unlike a traditional horror game
experience where I have the context of
the TV around me I'm in a room whatever
in VR you are truly immersed in that
world you're hearing like you can't hear
anything else you can't see anything
else and so that sense of dread that I
had throughout that entire experience
was incredible like I walked away and I
might the adrenaline pulsing through my
hand and I played that game the stakes
were so high when I was playing that
game like the first door you hear sounds
on the other side and I like would flick
it open and then immediately back away
and then I would go up to the crack in
the door that just made I would like
peer in I would peer in and then I'd be
like okay and say if I would open it but
that is the power that VR really
represents and the like it's it's like
metal gear but even more so because like
you feel personally invested in yeah
it's crazy Davey a big PR guy we don't
really for me vr it needs to like at
least experience so grateful for me when
VI really get special is when it's
allowing you to explore a world in a
depth you've never been able to go which
is why I was excited for things like
fallout 4 via because fallout as a world
that I've loved for a long time the idea
of seeing that much closer and
experiencing that in a new way as
genuinely exciting to me I want VR I
with the technology to give me
experiences that I would never be able
to have I won them I wanted to make me
forget that I'm looking at a screen
that's close to my eyes I want the
disconnects i want i want to just just
lose all like sense now i'm just sitting
in a chair which is why i find like the
resident evil fascinating because as
you're talking us think about it because
she
if you're walking down a corridor like
if you had a horror game you can turn it
around to see if someone's behind you in
VR like you'll be able to feel like
someone behind ya yeah at the same time
i'm not sure like the challenges around
it again talking about fallout for VR i
was talking to a jimmy [ __ ] last night
and he was saying when he was playing
because of the sensation that some VR
has called locomotion which is where
you're moving but it's not fooled your
body so you get motion sick yeah like
it's like the anti motion sickness still
make sure your office and to counter
that we've seen them we've seen like
dooms doing it fallouts doing it the
final fantasy demo we have warping your
own shooting yeah yeah the reason you're
walking around is because that's the way
to travel these worlds yea thou getting
motion sick right and that's like the
one thing that I feel like is just
breaking that immersion that I just
brave so hard the VR game that I'm most
excited about is it's for Farpoint the
issue only one is yeah literally because
it reminds me of playing with my little
brother running around our living room
on our guard and pretending to shoot
guns each other you're just pretending
you're in this this world like we would
run around I plays my little brother and
we'd say like our with bits space pirate
shoe and each other I'm a great time and
now like it's something I could
technically experience I've got the same
body motion i can still duck and cover
but now it's just brought that kind of
it's just bring into it like it sounds
like a PR lie but it feels like it's
bringing these dreams of these things to
life hmm yeah i actually got far points
another one that i got to test out and I
I have to say it was probably some of
the most satisfying first-person shooter
action that I'd ever had in a game ever
right where you brought up that
immersion factor of seen your hands in
the space getting to that tactile feel
so I got to play with the kind of like
their gun periphery which you know
everyone laughed about it when it was on
the wii you know like all the wheel
periphery and all the golf club
periphery but now all of a sudden psycho
look at the gun periphery so like full
sick on this yeah we've come a long way
from the days of the wii but like
holding kind of this just like you know
PVC pipe thing as kind of like a gun
like assault rifle and bringing it up to
my eye and being able to look through
the reticle and you know and see that
like spider aliens crawling on me and
and target them it was it was incredible
like I felt so empowered I felt so
immersed having my hands in that
position in holding something physical
yeah you know and having it respond to
me in real time in the space where I
could look under the gun and I could
tilted to the side I could like hold it
by one hand whatever like that was
incredibly immersive um and so I think
Farpoint was another one where it it did
do what VR is supposed to do right which
is kind of give you that immersive
experience and and it wasn't a teleport
game either which I agree the teleport
thing is is a weird part of the industry
right now um you know where I I don't
really want to point and click and
teleport around and so that's why you
know resident evil and Farpoint really
stood out to me because they were
physical motion through the space I mean
how big was the space that you walking
around in him in there plus it wasn't
actually me physically walking its but
its operating it using a control stick
right but it doesn't like it you're not
you're not feeling that sort of just
your helical say yeah and you can still
look around you and your kind of
strafing to the side with the control
stick but you know it helps immerse you
in that way without being like oh I'm
teleporting to this new location i'm
tellin to this new location like that I
think finds the right balance between
you know moving in the space versus
without making you sick um because that
was actually something for game lab my
new series we had to really consider so
each episode of game lab comes packaged
with a 360 video on oh yeah I have one
of these here though oh well there you
go so you can you can watch the whole
thing if you put your phone in here yeah
there or right it also can work on any
like a VR device that has like a youtube
app like so we actually would in working
on the show would watch it in the
headsets yeah to look just to give that
like immersive experience but one of the
things that I learned from shooting the
show was there are very specific rules
they have to follow a 360 and and to
avoid that kind of motion disconnect
that kind of throws off your equilibrium
you always have to have something that
stationary and stable in the space that
serves as a point of reference right so
like like the constant from lost yeah
yeah basically hi there's a chance
future reference lost you will own it
there's a hope it's useful I mean nobody
like is meant for Desmond oh yes they
show they it was for a couple seasons
don't
don't River this to me okay okay I'm
just pretending season six never
happened it's okay thank you uh but like
for instance we did an episode on rocket
League where we did our soccer in real
life and one of the things that you know
we had to be really conscious self was
sticking the VR cameras in a way where
you had the car as a frame of reference
so that way you didn't just see the road
spinning around you because that that's
what would make you sick if you have
that kind of stationary object that was
make that's what makes you feel
comfortable in the space we have another
episode that's all about like ostrich
riding like you would do a chocobo in
final fantasy and initially I'm like oh
I want to stay caviar camera on the
choke of on the ostrich so you can be
riding it to but because everything in
that situation moving and would be
jostling it was it was making everyone
sick and so we had to just cut that
footage and figure out different camera
angles but I the thing to remember is
that this is years 0 yeah or VR like the
headsets are just coming out now they're
slowly reaching consumer hands and so
there's that good there's going to be
that huge learning curve both in VR
video but also in vr gaming and so what
what is the best way to kind of immerse
people in this world what is the best
way to get people to move through the
space where they're not going to be
feeling that motion sickness and I think
Farpoint and resident evil to my mind
did a very very good job of it and other
ones where the teleporting yes it's a
functional way to do it but it does it
kind of you know serve as a barrier to
my experience in some capacity yes a
little bit so we told that we've talked
a lot about Sony actually but I don't
quite like the other competitors in the
space so obviously oculus got there
first they were the big name in VR they
were bought by Facebook for two billion
dollars which is insane and then you
know valve with their vibe technology
just came right out the bat and they had
none of the issues that people had
reported with oculus you know they came
out with better screens they came out
with no little to no lag or latency and
you can walk around and there was no
motion sickness and now these are both
available right and I feel like it
hasn't maybe hit certainly the
mainstream obviously we work with games
and so VR is all we hear about it hasn't
hit the mainstream as much as I kind of
thought it would but what's interesting
is that phones
of the ability like you can have an
iphone and you can load a VR experience
and no one seems to know about it is
there a problem with introducing VR to
the masses it's interesting because like
you said everyone's got these
possibilities on the phone and more and
more we're seeing like the Google
cardboard be shipped out and people and
people being told like hey you can do
this I think I think some people like
say the masses might think it's still a
little bit gimmicky but why think needs
to happen is there needs to be
competition like the reason we have so
many amazing xbox games so many
PlayStation games so many Nutella gates
is because they're competing to outdo
each other right yeah that's the reason
why like the HTC vive is doing is doing
well because they had to be better than
someone else we need all these like we
need the phones to compete and be like
they put stead in VR and compete to be
the best yeah buh ba VAR experience and
I think once they've got that kind of
thrust behind them and they realize that
they need this like surge of
competitiveness to like really bring it
to the masses that's when we'll see more
and more happen on the other hand when
I'm sitting on the tube and I do see
someone wearing their galaxy gear it is
a bit weird phone works again in the
while I've been sitting on the London
tube this guy's really here but his
phone is lap well as the phone this
thing and he's just like this headphones
on and I'm like how does he know where
his stop is is he just right in the
truth like we showed our daily circus
man where were you going it's actually a
big marketing gimmick like oh yeah it's
actually a big Samsung push that would
be funny but I know I think you're
totally right think that there's there's
a learning curve right now right there's
there's just so little VR content that's
hit mainstream there's so little 360
video that's out there and it's a
learning process right like that was one
of the reasons why I wanted to do BR
even though it's a big departure for
what my channel normally does as part of
game lab because one I want to immerse
the audience in in this but to I wanted
to start letting people know that this
is a thing that exists and you know to
start getting excited about it like you
can hold like the future is now and the
opportunity that this presents is really
cool where you can hold your earphone
and you can just look around or you can
use a cardboard headset or you can
invest in like the bigger like tethered
headset
and have like really visceral
experiences and I think all it's really
waiting for is what the killer app is
what is the first killer app for VR that
kind of cells everyone on this uh you
know x.x halo made Xbox happen right and
it put Xbox on the map it's like this is
an Xbox Live happen right exactly and so
you know what is that killer app going
to be for VR and actually that'll help
you know ease some of the confusion in
the space as well right because because
there is a lot of confusion there's you
you have the cardboard headsets you have
the you know the full-on vibe headset
with the hand controls you have oculus
with its controller set up you know do
you need a pc do you run it off of an
existing console like there's a lot of
variance depending on the headset that
you're using and you know the device and
experiences that the devices offer so
once there's more apps out there I think
once PPS vr goes out and you start
seeing people early adopters
experimenting with seeing this stuff and
educating the space about it that's when
you'll start to see it kind of like
disseminate outward but it's it's the
question of what is the game that is the
must play VR game out there and that's
going to really dictate who makes their
mark in this space first yeah what I
find interesting is coming back a little
bit to the Xbox Scorpio as they said
with all our teraflops and stuff we'll
be able to house we are so I'm really
interested to know if that's going to be
Microsoft's own they are they had that
augmented reality they had hollow leg
hololens which has been noticeably
absent for a while I was I was missing
it this year I would hear more from it
this year and then because that was one
of my highlights of last year actually
it was very impressive was where VR is
like in the immediate like that's kind
of this year in the next four years
hollow lens represents the next step
beyond that where augmented reality
becomes the next big thing some
interesting of Scorpio will be housing
the augmented reality from holland's or
they had some kind of deal with oculus
right where you get an xbox one
controller with an oculus but now it
seems that because they had todd howard
in that video right Todd gods as he's
known Howard obviously the fallout guy
Fallout and Bethesda VR is it going to
be a push to
I don't know it wouldn't surprise me if
they kind of brought a few companies
together to really push this yeah
because I know Microsoft has tried
connect and they've not worked maybe
they've learned something for their
peripheral world and they they're
confident and making their own kind of
VR experience I would think there'd be
more comfortable piggybacking off
someone else with a dedicated install
base already right that would make more
sense yeah yeah that does make sense
especially like you mention the oculus
connection and I mean I suppose oculus
does need their own kind of push in the
right direction because since the vibe
is taking over if Microsoft wanted to
you know from a few bucks and be like
hey so you can do with a bunch of this
money but you make VR for us mmhmm yeah
that wouldn't surprise me though right
but also I mean they're really making
Xbox a platform across pc so for PC you
know your honesty got the valve wrap
string like a very strong association is
already pre-existing up and it would
make sense for them to bring them on
board but at the same time valve and
vive itself is so big and they're on
their hardware partners HTC right it's
not gonna happen like well you it's
interesting you met the pc connection
because again you can use the occido
sort of pc and xbox are going hard on
everything on xbox everything on Windows
10 yeah yeah it wouldn't surprise me if
that made another oculus connection
rather than a 51 right yeah it'll be
interesting so what is it what has been
the best VR experience you guys have
ever had well the best experience I've
had with it is I walk down there there
was Villar porn I didn't wait what
really I didn't try it but I saw people
try it and that experience alone was
harrowing enough what a headset wasn't
operating I was Gary it was a gear VR
really okay there's no like tactile
control yeah sure i'm sad now Wow but
for me once I've actually tried like the
kind of weird ones like job simulator
okay the happiest I've been was when i
played euro truck simulator and I had
that we were in the office of the time
and I had the oculus on I'm there just
driving like a virtual truck with the
the wheel and the stick and everything
and I take it off and I'm like
it's been four hours and I've driven
Berlin but that was amazing the best
experiences for me of a weirdly enough
like the monotonous one yes did a
different universe I i adore like the
intense amazing new fantasy worlds ones
by the same time I'm like hey working
like we're gonna hot dog dance sounds
pretty cool right yeah it's in truck
simulator where their truck stops as
well that you got to go to or no oh yeah
like you have to like pull into like
I've never I've never see has so you
have to obey all the rules you have to
like you have to look we're like this
I'm pulling into a junction I have to
like my mirror I cannot drive a car
check your blog it's not it's fine yeah
I push your button to wind the window
down about this ya got that right nailed
it and then I'm away it was amazing
honestly like try it like wow it's one
of those things it's a hard sell to talk
about what yours is a try yeah that's
pretty good i'm convinced i love it
right that same type of Resident Evil
Farpoint all these magic games i'm just
like trucks down thy way of so for me I
would say what initially sold me on VR
was i I was at oculus last year the
booth here at e3 yeah I believe they
were showing a lien isolation and I
remember the moment that sold me on VR
was I heard the alien coming I saw it on
my map that it was coming I hid in the
locker that happened to be nearby and I
was looking at the alien as it walked
passed through the slats yes in the
locker and as he got close to the locker
i slumped down my seat and my eyesight
slumped down with me and I was like oh
my gosh I I didn't realize I could do
that and then he started to pick up and
I started like crane my neck and all of
my actions were replicated in the game
it was like I was really looking through
those slaps and you know hiding in fear
for my life and that's the moment where
I'm like this is a really cool
opportunity this is a really this is
going to be game-changing for these
experiences so that was definitely one
of the one of the best but as far as
like longer for because that was a very
short experience longer form it's a
heart it's a toss-up between resident
evil and fire points our point was so
satisfying being immersed in that world
and having a really quality shooter
experience but resident evil was so
viscerally
terrifying the entire time that like
it's not something I'm going to forget
anytime soon like I had a hard time
sleeping that night it was a tense so
definitely those two are competing for
number one but wasn't evil is like it's
the grandson to kitchen right yeah it
was kinda cake they put the seven in the
kitchen logo that's so clever I know
right I'm like congratulations on you
like that was smart good night my
ultimate VR experience is the the vibe
tech demo where you're the bottom of the
sea understanding on the the bow of a
sunken ship and you're like looking
around and then you hear this big noise
I don't know you get distracted by a
stingray right and you're just standing
there like looking at it and like poking
it fish and they'll come next to you and
then you hear this big goes you turn
around and it's this enormous whale and
it's the enormity of it is what really
gets you and the sound effects in there
and you look at it in the eye you have
this really weird if you've seen ferris
bueller's day off like the bit where
he's at the art museum and he's looking
at the painting you have that kind of a
moment with a whale that's not there but
it feels like it is and that was the
moment for me where I just was like all
right I mean yeah all we talk about via
the more I think we're one step and step
away from being plugged into the matrix
or just losing all oh I've got the
credit card ready all right I'm ready
man yeah you're ready or sign you up I'm
getting real world ready player one yeah
oh absolutely this is terrifying we're
all sword art online there's another one
you I just lock in and you're gone for
days but guys we're gonna be talking
about the best surprises from e3 next
song we're gonna be talking about our
favorite things that we've seen at the
show so please don't go anywhere keep
your eyes peeled to gamespot com
you